hoy día de la victoria venimos aquí a
conocer a anna que cuando estalló la
segunda guerra mundial tenía cinco años
ana
ivette 1er jana no recibe en la puerta
de su casa vivió la segunda guerra
mundial y siempre ha festejado la
victoria de la unión soviética sobre la
alemania nazi en 1945 pero este año no
es como cualquier otro
es una buena celebración pero este año
lo celebramos con lágrimas deberíamos
vivir en paz y
ahora ya no sueña con el fin de este
conflicto
estévez estas nos tienen que dejar vivir
en paz yo quiero morir en paz decía que
está con la guerrilla
amnesia nikolayeva nació en 1932 su
abuela fue asesinada por los nazis pero
también está dolida por la guerra que
inició el presidente ruso vladimir putin
en ucrania
esa guerra me asustó mucho fue mi
primera guerra tenía nueve años y no
entendía nada no entiendo a putin yo lo
respetaba pero ahora cuando lo veo
pienso que no es un hombre que es el
el
hoy la guerra continúa en ucrania y el
dolor para conesa illana se repite